welcome back to CBS Saturday morning
former president Trump visits a key
state in the race for the Republican
Presidential nomination Trump is
scheduled to visit Iowa early next week
he's following former U.N Ambassador
Nikki Haley who announced her candidacy
last month and Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis who is widely expected to
announce his run as well CBS News Chief
election and campaign correspondent
Robert Costa is in the Hawkeye State as
the race takes shape
it's Iowa and the race is on in these
early days of the 2024 presidential race
nearly everyone with ambition in the
Republican Party seems to be coming here
and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis a
potential Challenger to former president
Donald Trump made his first trip to Iowa
on Friday touting his latest
best-selling book and his record and
telling a conservative audience that he
is one of them so in your book uh the
courage to be free you talk about
growing up in Florida in a spring
training town and you call it your own
little Baseball Heaven but you do know
where Baseball Heaven is
[Applause]
influential Iowa conservative Bob Vander
Platt says the field is wide open
there's a lot of Republicans who really
like what president Trump did and the
Trump Administration did
but there's a real pause is he the right
one to carry the Baton in 2024. and I
think if Trump gets stalled here in Iowa
if he gets defeated here in Iowa I think
it's game on to a nomination a newly
released poll of Iowan shows the
favorability numbers for Trump and
DeSantis are nearly even sensing and
opening others are keeping busy in Iowa
including former U.N Ambassador Nikki
Haley who has been holding Town Halls
this week this National self-loathing
that has happened in our country
the idea that people say America's bad
or rotten or racist and Trump will visit
Iowa on Monday as he continues to try to
rally his core supporters to push him
back toward the nomination for a third
time and there is growing competition
between former president Trump and
Governor DeSantis before Trump's visit
to this state next week in fact a trump
adviser Jason Miller tells CBS news that
no one including DeSantis should get a
free pass in Iowa and Miller says the
Trump campaign will try to highlight
desantis's positions on Social Security
and Medicare and federal spending in the
coming days for CBS Saturday morning
Robert Costa Des Moines Iowa